well Obama's calling a top Democrat
staging a Biden intervention and we're
not talking about Hunter although that
would be pretty good too Barack Obama
telling President Biden that he better
get off the beach and start campaigning
or he's going to lose his re-election
and we might lose our lunch having to
stare at those man boobies Barack
reportedly telling Joe his concerns
quote we're not about Biden's political
abilities but rather recognition of
Trump's iron grip on the Republican
Party Obama also promising his old pal
he will quote do all he can to help
Biden keep his job but Biden should
probably be lit the worried about his
standings in his own party even the
liberal media questioning Joe's ability
to make it past the Finish Line watch
the question is how solid a candidate is
Joe Biden that's the problem that's
exactly the problem and and what is
exactly the problem that we don't know
how solid a candidate Joe Biden is we
know he's not a solid kid he's
struggling I mean
it is hard to watch Donald Trump's
approval ring was actually slightly
larger than uh Joe Biden's was at this
point Trump was at 43 Biden is it just
41 so he's doing worse than Trump who he
was always saying was doing so poorly
look at the numbers uh Joe Biden's uh
support has dropped significantly among
people of color uh especially among
Latino voters but also among black
Americans
when you've lost Joe and Mika you've
lost the fight Hunter Shady business
deals also dragging the big guy down a
majority of Americans now think Joe's
Administration is unethical but don't
worry Joe knows how to seem relatable to
voters he's rolling out his alter ego
cringe dark Brandon
my coffee door
dark oh dear lord yeah that's uh a lot
of this is shaping up to be pretty
problematic for the president so what do
you think the President should do when
he's faced with the advice from former
president Obama how seriously should he
take that Council that Donald Trump is
more formidable a better candidate and
more of a threat than Biden and other
Democrats feel
well I think a lot of Democrats think
that running against Donald Trump again
uh for Joe Biden would be not easy but
preferable I thought President Obama if
indeed he gave him that advice was very
very smart advice we've said on this
show many times before at least I've
tried to that um President Biden any
incumbent when you get towards the times
when you're running for re-election you
got to get out and Define and brag about
what you've done over the last few years
for the country
you got to speak to the aspirations of
the country and even be vulnerable about
what you may not have been able to
accomplish and then Advocate like the
day the day is never going to end about
how you're going to make the world
better how you're going to make the
country better for them and their kids
we're in the middle of a campaign my
advice to the White House I know the
president and Mrs Biden deserve some
time off but no more pictures on the
beach no uh everyday Americans are
getting ready to go back to school you
got half the country to be back in
school with their kids in the next week
or so
um get out and do the things you need to
do in order to remind us why we voted
for you those of us that did and even
those that may not have voted for you
why they should consider voting for you
again I think thinking that that Donald
Trump is going to be the nominee and
thinking he's going to be a less than
formidable candidate is exactly the
wrong thing to do so I give kudos to
former president Obama for giving him
that advice all right so Jesse leaning
into the whole dark Brandon thing and
that was dumb I'm sorry and that was
please stop that you gotta stop that but
you know you have to do something to
overcome the hunter Trump because with
Devin Archer's testimony before the
house oversight committee this week the
the circle around the president is
tightening his lies or you know his half
truth whatever you want to call them
they seem to be catching up with them is
dark Brandon enough to overcome
less than light Hunter no it's not
enough remember dark Brandon came from
let's go Brandon yeah which came from
you you know what yep so the political
consultant tried to capitalize off that
goofy smear and this is what they came
up with
funny because he is a dark guy he's a
nasty guy he's arresting his rival and
he's been shaking down Chinese and
Ukrainian Executives for years and
hiding it he's nasty to his family to
his granddaughter he's a nasty guy he
says calls people white supremacists
he's not a nice guy so it they're kind
of funny about it but there's some
darkness in his soul now Obama's big
brother in this guy they hate each other
really they hate each other these two
remember he only chose Biden as VP
because he was a white guy who had
foreign policy chops and knew his way
around Washington to balance that ticket
and he gets in there and Barack never
took him seriously they would laugh at
him behind his back and we always
remember he said you know
he's gonna f it up eventually and he
kind of is as they said about Brandon
and he is messing it up when you look at
the hunter stuff and now it's his stuff
it's more of a Biden scandal than a
hunter scandal so Obama's going to come
in and say you know what to everybody
after this meeting and leak it and I was
like Hey Joe you know I'm here if you
need me because uh Trump's pretty tough
so let me know what you need me to do
the Obama right so he's trying to get a
little Shine off it now Biden without
the pandemic is a weak candidate yes
without the pandemic they see he can't
raise money uh his numbers are bad and
he's just not galvanizing the Democratic
party so
with the ethics problems the way it is
you might not have him as the nominee
you might have Gavin Newsom and Gretchen
Whitmer as the ticket I mean that that's
what they're going to have to jockey and
really figure out in short order Martha
as you know better than anyone these
debates are coming up fast and furious
on the Republican side of this President
seems like he is essentially
unchallenged but the problem is as Jesse
points out they're having money and
they're having trouble rather raising
Grassroots money right now so when does
it reach critical mass yeah I would love
we'd all love to have been a fly on the
wall in that meeting because Jessie's
exactly right that is a very fraught
relationship between the two of them
remember that Obama
um you know gave Hillary the tap to run
and his Vice President Joe Biden that's
a that's around the same time that he
decided to dig in deep to these foreign
business ventures because he was like I
guess I'm not not going to run for
president I'm going to be on my own I
might as well make some money uh and
figure out what Hunter's been doing on
all of these trips and see if I can sort
of tap into some of that it appears
based on all the information that we've
gotten from Devin Archer and Tony
bobolinski and everyone else about him
being at these meetings but he did Obama
never wanted him to run right and there
was even discussions about him one you
know coming back and saying Joe you
don't have to do this right you don't
have to run for president and I think
there was a big inclination on the
president's part based on a lot of
reporting out there that that he wanted
to prove to Obama that he could do it
you know that he that he could push
things further than Obama and on some
things he got further to the left than
Obama on certain issues so now his big
problem is that he has to convince
people that he should have another term
um you know I I would love to know what
his reaction was to President Obama if
he took that advice here seriously if he
thinks that Trump is really a threat If
he if he knows what to do to to get
himself more traction out there what
does he do right he can't campaign from
the basement anymore he is now burdened
not only with the issue of his age and
infirmity which is on video all over the
place case he's also burdened by this
Hunter situation which people are
increasingly concerned about and looking
at that and saying well you know Trump's
got these indictments Hunter Biden is
you know President Biden's got these
problems but they don't have anybody to
step up and fill that void that's the
one thing he's got going for him right
now what do they do Taurus well they're
doing what they're doing they're
arresting
and dieting their biggest competition if
you can't if you can't beat them you got
to get rid of them so that's where he's
going the problem with this entire
Administration has been
all the information and they think
Americans have a short memory that's not
how it is anymore in this country we are
paying attention now minorities we're
paying attention we're watching politics
like sports now we're paying attention
to what the people we vote for what
they're doing now when we got into the
pandemic is why and Jesse was right and
he got it now we're learning all the
information that we were got during the
pandemic he was lying to us the guy who
was supposedly the liar and the criminal
was telling us like it is he told us
where it came from he told us that the
vaccines need to be looked at more all
those things that Trump said have come
to be true and all the things that he
said has become to be untrue in the
Americans remember that plus you walk
out of your house there's no more police
officers around anymore you take your
kids are two years behind on school
there's you're get there's new jobs but
there's no hours so there's all these
things happening to the American people
and then when you look at him one you
can't get a press conference without
being told that it'll have to wait to
another press conference or two if you
get him the talk he gets frustrated and
upset because unfortunately father time
has not been kind to him so he can't
debate president Trump so the only way
you can do is show up at a debate and be
like well I'm here to debate where is he
oh he's locked up oh well then I win and
so that's the strategy one thousand
percent or somebody has to be the adult
in the room and say Gavin it's your time
yes
I always I feel like she gets I feel
like she's been locked out of this
Administration since she's been in it
and this has been in the desire to make
her look bad to protect President Biden
I think if given an opportunity this is
a chance for her at some point to say
enough she's made herself look bad
yeah I agree but she's not getting
helped either dark branded Brandon dark
Brandon is giving Kamala so much shade I
had Democrats and the media want Trump
Behind Bars without a fair trial we will
discuss next hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now